well the White House Correspondents
Dinner speaking of dinners is going to
limp along this Saturday night despite
the fact that for the first time in 36
years the president will not be
attending by the way the only reason
Reagan didn't go back in 1981 is because
he was recovering from a gunshot
wound as opposed to President Trump who
will not be attending because he's
recovering from but hurt wounds and
because traditionally the president
inspected deliver a funny speech but as
we all know Donald Trump is the comedic
timing of a grease fire in a dumpster
fire so in past years the Correspondents
Dinner has been the second highest rated
program on c-span after like this
look at that
Wow still better than season two of true
detective I'm not going to be honest I
got to be honest seems doubtful the
people tune in to this year's dinner
without the possibility of Trump
insulting an entire race or accidentally
setting wolf Blitzer's beard on fire so
what is something c-span could do to get
its ratings up this weekend Moshe kasher
you're going to broadcast the audio of
Trump bragging about grabbing Mitch
McConnell by that neck all right
[Applause]
Happy Thanksgiving
do-si-do thing you think you think first
off neck has to trend is a hashtag
that's why and to someone watching just
watch you simulate eating out a turkey
and and they got a little hard
I'm sorry Joe Paul Ryan for zen p90x
yeah yes Anthony Weiner's parade of dick
pics yeah
[Applause]